would you ever consider getting a face
tattoo
never never
i get it you know a face tattoo is no
different than a nipple piercing
from 20 years ago 30 years ago anyway
you end up looking like a
notebook from high school
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my first tattoo technically i gave
myself
with a needle and indian ink
in the basement of my grandmother's
house uh such a
me and my friends would just sit there
and we would just
give ourselves these crappy little
tattoos and i had them
i had it i had them all the way up until
i was about 19 when i got my first
real tattoo which is actually
this one right here and it's such savage
early 90s garbage that i can't even tell
you
this was the very first tribal s tattoo
this was after uh joey came up with the
design and i thought it was so
cool that i immediately went to one of
our local
uh tattoo artists and i had him give it
to me nobody else in the band got the
yes because they all had
the logo like everybody in the band had
slipknot
the slipknot logo i'm probably the only
dude
left from the original band
that doesn't have the slipknot logo but
i'm covered in s's
i think the first cool tattoo i ever got
well besides the one on my chest but
that kind of bled out
is my heath ledger and i love it because
of the detail
you know like the views to this day it's
still really vibrant i mean i got this
thing 12 years ago
my favorite i mean i have i have a few
to be honest obviously my bowie is is
pretty rad
and i love it because i have the the
bowie logo right here which is one of my
favorite logos
but i also love my s thompson
what's the most painful place to get
tattoos what for you chest
chest oh my god the chest my chest
tattoo
took uh two sittings the gray and white
wash side
was pretty simple i mean we did that in
about two hours
this side took if i remember correctly
seven hours and it was some of the worst
most painful drilling i've ever felt
because when because you're getting
drilled
here you're feeling it all through your
arms up into your neck and i just
remember just being paralyzed and i just
kept going are we done yet
like i am no hero you know i
just i'm not a fan of the pain but my
chest tattoo
actually came from an idea that i had um
which is
the you know the sun and the moon which
uh paul booth did
it was supposed to represent
the yin and yang of the kind of struggle
between
light and dark and all of us and that's
kind of where all of my tattoos kind of
come from you know like they've all
been representations of duality the fact
that we're all made up of different
parts no person is all
horrible no person is all good we are
all
made up of dueling fates that
are you know that can change from day to
day
i'm working on a back piece right now
that would probably be
my last round of tattoos because i'm
i'm obviously i'm running out of real
estate i'm actually doing a uh
a a montage of horror icons
kind of starting with the the universal
monsters but not
doing the universal monsters i'm
actually starting with the hammer horror
uh films so that's going to be my uh
kind of up like upgraded montage
of you know the the universal monster
tropes
the only people who i really knew who
had tattoos were criminals and rock
stars
you know like it's like that was it at
the time this was like the
late 80s you know um it wasn't until the
mid 90s when it became something that
was attainable
i started seeing more and more people
with tattoos
in the culture and in the scene i never
had any aspirations about having
a lot of tattoos man like i thought
honestly i would just
i would get a couple and i was i was
fine with just having little bits and
pieces but then
you get them it's such a great
representation of
of things inside of you you know i feel
like this is more of who i
am you know it's uh it's something
that's important i don't think a lot of
people have that